SOMETHING THE WHITE HOUSE IS
CROWING ABOUT TONIGHT.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU, ED, GREAT
TO SEE YOU.
REPUBLICAN SENATORS ARE PUSHING
A DACA DEAL TO PROVIDE AMNESTY
TO ABOUT TWO MILLION ILLEGAL
IMGRANTSES.
PROPOSING A WHICH IS BEING
PROMOTED BY 7 REPUBLICANS,
INCLUDING LINDSAY GRAHAM OF
SOUTH CAROLINA, WOULD OFFER A
PATH TO CITIZENSHIP FOR ALL
SO-CALLED DREAMERS, EVEN THOSE
NOT PART OF DACA, ELIGIBLE FOR
WELFARE AFTER FIVE YEARS.
.
DIVERSITY LOTTERY WOULD BE,
QUOTE, ABOLISHED, VISAS WOULD BE
REALLOCATED TO OTHER PERHAPS
WITH THE SAME PURPOSE.
SLIGHT OF HAND.
ALLOWS THE PARENTS OF DOCKCA
RECIPIENTS WHO ILLEGALLY ENTERED
AMERICA AS ADULTS AND CAUSED
THIS PROBLEM, TO GET RENEWABLE
WORK PERMITS TO SAY IN THE
COUNTRY.
DO YOU CARE ABOUT BORE DESHS, IT
IS AER -- BORDERS, IT IS A PAR
ON DI.
-- PARODY.
CONGRESSWOMAN, THANKS FOR BEING
ON.
NOT ONLY A MEMBER OF CONGRESS,
SPENT YEARS IN UNIFORM.
>> YES.
>> Tucker: OVER 20, I THINK.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS SAYING, BASICALLY,
OUTLOUD PROVIDE AMNESTY OR WE’LL
STOP PAYING OUR TROOPS.
>> IT’S INFURIATING, I BROUGHT
THIS UP IN A WHITE HOUSE MEETING
LAST WEEK, I WAS MOVED WHEN I
HEARD DICK DURBIN SAY THERE’S
LIVES HANGING IN THE BALANCE OR
SOMETHING LIKE.
THAT I WAS LIKE MOVED TO JUMP IN
AND SAY THE ONLY LIVES HANGING
IN THE BALANCE RIGHT NOW ARE
THOSE OF OUR MILITARY.
THE MEN AND WOMEN SERVING
OVERSEAS, PUTSING THEIR LIVES IN
HARM’S WAY, THERE’S A FAKE
DEADLINE CREATED BY THE
DEMOCRATS HOLDING THEM HOSTAGE.
WHILE OUR TROOPS ARE OVER THERE
RISKING THEIR LIVES FOR US?
THEY’RE PICKING AROUND, TRYING
TO COME UP WITH SOME ISSUE
THAT’S NOT IN THE TOP 20
PRIORITY OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE NEED TO LOOK TO MORE
LEGISLATION LIKE THE BILL I
INTRODUCED LAST WEEK THAT
ADDRESSES THE PRIORITIES OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BORDER SECURITY, ENDING CHAIN
MIGRATION, ENDTION THE VISA
LOTTERY, UNACCOMPANIED MINOR.
THIS ADDRESSES THE ROOT CAUSES
OF DACA, WE CAN WORK ON.
THERE IS NO CRISIS HERE.
THEY’RE HOLDING OUR TROOPS
HOSTAGE FOR THIS ISSUE THAT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH FUNDING OUR
MILITARY.
INFURIATING.
>> Tucker: THE BILL THAT YOU ARE
BACKING IS LITERALLY MAIN STREAM
IN THAT ITS MAJOR COMPONENTS ARE
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE POLLING ON
THE QUESTION.
>> EXACTLY.
>> Tucker: BUT THE SENATE
VERSION WHICH IS BEING SUPPORTED
REALLY DRIVEN BY LINDSAY GRAHAM
AND JEFF FLAKE, LINDSAY GRAHAM
SAID JEFF FLAKE WILL DO WHATEVER
I TELL HIM TO DO.
A BENCH OF REPUBLICAN SENATORS.
IT’S VERY FAR FROM WHAT YOU
PROPOSE.
>> IT IS.
>> Tucker: CAN YOU WIN THEM TO
YOUR SIDE?
>> WE HAVE TO.
THIS IS A PRIORITY OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE WORKED FOR 4 1/2 MONTHS ON
THIS BILL F YOU LOOK AT THE
WHITE HOUSE PUT OUT A DOCUMENT
WITH 70 REQUESTS.
WE WORKED THU THEM ALL.
NOT ALL OF THEM, THIS IS A VERY
REASONABLE PRIORITIZED PROPOSAL
THAT FOCUSES ON SECURITY, FIRST
AND FOREMOST, OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
ADDRESS AS LOOPHOLE IN OUR
SYSTEM, SOME OF THEM ARE
CREATING THREATS LIKE WE’VE SEEN
WITH THE TERRORIST ATTACKS IN
NEW YORK CITY.
THEY HAVE TO BE CLOSED.
WITH THE CHAIN MIGRATION AND THE
VISA LOTTERY SYSTEM.
IF WE’RE WILLING TO DO SOMETHING
ON DACA, THAT WE ARE NOT FINDING
OURSELVES IN THE SITUATION AGAIN
IN ANOTHER ONE, FIVE, TEN YEARS.
THIS IS A VERY REASONABLE
APPROACH.
SHOULD BE THE STARTING POINT.
THAT’S WHAT WE NEED TO SIT DOWN
AND NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH.